[GOOGLE AUDIO TRADEMARK]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[KEYBOARD KEYS CLICKING]
- Have you ever
dreamed you could fly?
Come and see.
- Why is a girl like
you taking coding class?
- Our whole lives,
we're told by the world
that if we don't
look like Steve Jobs,
we can't work with technology.
And I don't like
being told what to do.
- I love your imagination.
It's your superpower.
- This is code.
And with it, you can create
anything you set your mind to.
- Imagine a world but we can
give a voice to the voiceless.
- Play Andy's song.
[KEYBOARD PLAYING CHORD]
- I'm going to make
a whole new world.
- Everything is connected.
- Take me with you
into the future.
- Time's up.
Ready girls?
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
JENNA ORTEGA: Cool, all right.
Yeah, first of all, I want to
say it's super-exciting seeing
the turnout, and how inspired--
I know I left the
films very inspired,
and I hope you guys did as well.
And it's nice to see plenty of
young girls and boys excited
about coding and all that.
So we're going to
get into this panel--
super-empowered.
I'm super-excited
to be sitting next
to all of these amazing women.
First question I
have for you guys--
what excited you
about the opportunity
to direct one of
these short films?
Anyone can go first,
whoever just feels it first.
MARISA POLVINO: In
order of most important.
JULIE BOWEN: That's
going be Nikki.
NIKKI REED: I feel like it's
always weird to talk first,
so I'll just jump in,
and then I'll just--
JULIE BOWEN: Quit, Nikki.
NIKKI REED: --sound less
eloquent than all of you,
and then you'll take off.
My film was first.
I'll go first.
I think I love the
idea of telling
a story that was aspirational
and inspirational,
but also felt grounding, and
dealt with real-life issues,
and topics, and things
that are uncomfortable.
And I think we all kind of did
that in some capacity and--
JULIE BOWEN: Not me.
[LAUGHTER]
NIKKI REED: I love learning
and growing with a project.
And this was
something-- this issue
was something that was
brought to my attention
by Marisa and Straight Up.
And when the project
presented itself,
I felt even more motivated to
tell a story about young women
to hopefully
inspire young women.
JENNA ORTEGA: Amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
That was a beautiful answer.
NIKKI REED: Now someone say
something else more articulate.
ROSARIO DAWSON:
I'll answer second
because I was in your
film, and you hit me up.
I think you DMed me or
texted me or something.
NIKKI REED: I have your number.
ROSARIO DAWSON: Yeah, you
texted me, you texted me, sorry.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Hey, Ava [INAUDIBLE]
got me in her video.
She slid into my DMs.
It's the way it's done now.
That's how I got Zoe Luna
to be a part of the project
when we were casting and looking
for a trans girl actresses,
we were having a
really hard time.
And we got a lot of trans boys
who showed up for the audition,
but we didn't get
any trans girls.
And I was really wanting
it to be really real.
JENNA ORTEGA: Wait, that
young woman is a trans girl?
ROSARIO DAWSON:
Yes, she became--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JULIE BOWEN: She's a
phenomenal actress.
ROSARIO DAWSON:
Yeah, she's great--
and so literally slid into her
DMs because my friend was like,
oh, I don't know her personally,
but she was in this Quinceañera
documentary, and maybe
you should ask her.
And I called her--
I DMed her.
And then she came in 45
minutes to the screening.
I was crazy, it was amazing,
and she came through.
It was great.
But I just want
to say the reason
why I jumped into the
directing whole thing is
because I had FOMO.
[GROANS AND LAUGHTER]
So it was a lot more like
your character in "Girl Code"
than you know.
But it really was sort of
just like, hi, I'm on set,
this is so great--
with Gina and Nikki--
and what's happening
here, and how
come no one asked me to direct?
[LAUGHTER]
MARISA POLVINO: And
which we immediately did.
NIKKI REED: Thank you for
being a part of our movie.
ROSARIO DAWSON: I
was like, oh, wow.
It's incredible.
So thank you so much,
and thank you so much.
It was just a dream
come true to be
able to see how this industry
that I've grown up in
and is such an
opportunity to continue
to keep pushing boundaries, and
stretching our imaginations,
and inspiring us, and pushing us
to be that much greater than we
think we can be.
And that challenge was
just really exceptional,
and I'm really grateful.
JENNA ORTEGA: Amazing.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JENNA ORTEGA: All right.
ANA BRENDA CONTRERAS:
And I also think
that the fact that
we, ourselves, got out
of our comfort
zone as actresses,
and we are encouraging young
girls to do the same thing,
it was like a double-win
in so many ways.
I think for me,
it was definitely
out of my comfort zone.
JENNA ORTEGA: You guys got
me wanting to direct as well.
Maybe in the future-- we'll see.
That would be really cool.
I'll hop on to the second
question I have for you guys.
So in all of these
different shorts,
there were different
types of technologies,
and there was also different
types of inspiration.
So did any of you guys find
inspiration in these films,
and if you did, connect
it to the film--
how did you make that
personal connection?
LISA EDELSTEIN: When we
were given this assignment,
I was trying to figure out--
I was trying to relate to
myself as a young girl.
And so I thought a lot
about what inspired me
as an imaginative young girl.
And the thoughts
that Lulu has about
trying to imagine infinity and
trying to understand atoms,
all that were things that
blew my mind when I was young.
So I really wanted to--
I felt like that was my
way in to remember what
it was like to be 8 to 18,
and really just discovering,
and being mind-expanding.
Everything's mind-expanding
when you're that age.
So yeah, that's why I did it.
JENNA ORTEGA: Sweet.
JULIE BOWEN: I thought of my
niece, who was 13 at the time.
And that was kind of
our target demographic,
of young women who are
leaving science and math all
of a sudden, or not staying
the course-- not you girls,
I know you are.
And I thought, what
would she watch?
What would she not click
through and go, eh.
And I thought she needed to see
aspirational, lovely people,
but also you need to
dump the mom as fast
as you can in my experience.
To the fact that we each
had a piece of technology
in our short, and mine was
the Waymo, the driverless car.
And I thought that was a good
opportunity to dump the mom.
So if that's
personally resonating,
then that's how it
personally represented.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JULIE BOWEN: Dump the mom.
NIKKI REED: So I'm
learning coding right now.
JENNA ORTEGA: No way.
NIKKI REED: I am.
[APPLAUSE]
I started a company
two years ago.
I've not been acting
anymore, actually.
I started a company
two years ago
that focuses on
using extracted gold
from the motherboards
of recycled technology
to make fine jewelry.
And we also use
cultivated diamonds,
so diamonds that are grown
from a diamond seed that
are molecularly
identical to diamonds
without the environmental
consequences.
And--
LISA EDELSTEIN:
(SINGING) Boring.
NIKKI REED: Sorry, the long--
[APPLAUSE]
That was a mouthful, I know.
But I wear many hats
with the company--
JULIE BOWEN: Do something.
NIKKI REED: --and one
of them is coding.
Sorry, that was a long spiel.
I say it fast now.
One of them is coding.
And I think one of the
things that I love so much
about wearing so many
hats in a company
is learning about
each of those areas.
And I'm learning
coding, and I know
how to work the back
end of my website,
and building all of that myself.
So I feel really inspired
by all of this as well.
And it's amazing to see
multiple industries overlap--
fashion and tech, and
the intersection of that.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
ANA BRENDA CONTRERAS: For me,
it was very, very personal
journey, because I recently
lost my dad like two months
before they invited
me to this project.
And I was reading
all the log lines,
and I read the story
by [? Borja, ?]
who is here somewhere.
Thank you, [? Borja, ?]
you're amazing.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And I was like, oh my
god, this is meant to be.
I have to do this.
I have to honor my
dad in a way, and also
talk about achieving
your goals, your dreams,
but also about grieving,
and also about feeling lost,
and just pushing and keep going,
because eventually you'll fly,
and you're going to make it.
So in so many ways, it
was a journey for me.
And I grieved through it as
well, just like the character.
JENNA ORTEGA: So sorry.
Thank you.
Thank you for
that, we felt that.
I felt that watching that.
Amazing.
We very much appreciate you.
Something I guess we
could play off of this--
and you could just come up
first for this next one, what
was the most rewarding part
about watching your film
once it was all put together?
ANA BRENDA CONTRERAS: Oh, god,
I tried not to cry, so, so bad.
And you are all
amazing, by the way.
I totally respect
you, and I feel
honored to be here tonight
with you sharing the stage.
I don't know, like,
seeing it all together.
And also the fact-- we were
talking about this earlier--
the fact that we, as actresses,
are out of our comfort zone,
trying a different field.
And I feel like the
message that I'm sending
and what I'm inviting young
girls to do, I did it myself,
in a way.
So it's like, kudos
for me, in a way.
Also, it's like,
great, I did it.
So it was a great
feeling for me.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIE BOWEN: I'm a
little in love down here.
What was the question?
I was just watching her?
JENNA ORTEGA: What was most
rewarding about watching
the short once it was presented?
JULIE BOWEN: Oh, I kept leaning
to all of these women who
made me cry, one after the
other, after the other,
and I was like, get ready
for some empty calories.
We're going to
finish real light.
Have you ever tried to make
it dinner out of cotton candy?
[LAUGHTER]
Because I knew I'd
made something light,
but I made it purposely
light because I wanted it--
I kept thinking, what
would my niece watch?
And boy, I can't even imagine--
of course, she'll
watch all of these,
and she'll probably weep and
cry, and then go, Aunt Julie,
please.
But I thought--
ANA BRENDA CONTRERAS: I was
so thankful for your movie.
I was like, yes, I want
to laugh, I want to laugh.
JULIE BOWEN: Sometimes you need
to bury the message a little,
and so I was excited to
see that the audience was
ready for that.
It was fun to hear them laugh.
So that's what was
exciting for me.
And to see my son on screen,
Harris, with the drone--
one of my kids.
He's at home, doing
homework right now.
[APPLAUSE]
ROSARIO DAWSON: I'd
actually like to say--
I wanted to bring up-- and
so many of the things that I
brought up on my short are
all the things that stop us--
bullying, I wanted to talk about
that, and how devastating that
can be.
People commit-- I mean,
people commit themselves
to just shutting down,
and not developing,
and not showing up because
they don't feel like they
have that support out there.
I wanted to talk
about how dangerous,
how much information
we put online,
and how vulnerable
we make ourselves,
and how we have to be
smarter about that.
I wanted to bring
up how important it
is to reach out
and ask for help,
and to trust your friends,
and trust your community
to be there for you so you
can problem-solve together
when something's too
overwhelming for you.
It's like, in a spiritual
sense, which I just
love, so much of that.
There's so much heart,
and spirit, and humor,
and laughter, and
connection, and reality
that's embedded in all of
these films, which I think
is just so important.
And just that reality of
just that heart space.
You've got to protect.
And I'm a big fan of-- we all
have a space in the circle.
We're not separate
from each other.
We're all holding
hands in that circle.
And oftentimes, when we get
hurt, when we feel vulnerable,
when we get scared, we
pull away from the circle
and we step back.
And those are the
moments where we
need to step in, and
be held in the circle,
and have everybody
else support us
until we can stand
back in that circle,
and support somebody else.
And I just wanted to have
things like that show up,
and see how they
problem-solved those things.
Do you give up the friendship?
Do you all just fight, and
just walk away, and give up?
Or do you empower each other,
and go, no, you're right,
and I can actually
see why you gave up--
and you were trying
to protect us,
and I see that, but no, because
this is bigger, actually,
than all of us individually.
And none of those things
that this person is trying
to exploit about us
that we put online,
that makes us
sensitive and personal,
is anything that
could defeat us.
Because we've also grown
from those experiences.
And those experiences
didn't stop us,
so this one won't, either.
And I just kind
of wanted to show
that in so many ways, especially
the idea-- it's subtle,
but just the idea
of how many people
were possibly in this
contest, and why did he
pick those girls to
try to take down?
Why did he feel like
he was threatened?
In some ways people are really
interested in seeing girls
in science and tech.
So maybe he thought
they'd have so much shine
that he would not be able to
get attention on his as a boy.
So I wanted to just kind
of-- and not totally
demonize him and make
him this horrible person.
It wasn't so much
that he's exploiting
these different things
because he really truly
is misogynistic, and
homophobic, and transphobic,
and all these things.
It's actually more so the
extent that he's vulnerable,
and he's scared,
and he has issues.
And maybe he doesn't
have people around him
to support him to let him know
that what he's doing is enough,
and that he doesn't need to
take away from someone else,
and someone else doesn't have
to lose in order for him to win.
So it was just--
a lot of that stuff was
peppered in there, the things
that I've seen over, and
over, and over again,
but I just wanted to
see flipped on its head,
and see these girls
problem-solve.
And when-- Zoe Bell is
in it, and Tracie Thoms
is in it, who I've done multiple
films with both of them.
And it was sort of like an
Easter egg, of just going--
you know, I met
Tracie on "Rent,"
and then we auditioned
for "Deathproof,"
and then she didn't
get the role.
And we were like, no,
we went in together.
And we got the role.
And then we became really
great friends with Zoe,
and Zoe produced
something, and she cast us.
And it's just been this
thing where we've continued
to show up for each other.
And it was just that.
And these three girls are in
that really precarious moment,
like, is this friendship
going to break
or are they going to
get stronger and end up
having a history of
showing up for each other
and knowing that they can depend
on each other like true family?
And so all of that stuff, I
thought, was just so important.
The things that stop us, it's
so often just a connection away,
a communication away
from being resolved.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNA ORTEGA: Wow.
All right, to kind of
switch this subject,
I'm going to make you
guys think a little bit--
LISA EDELSTEIN: Damn it.
JENNA ORTEGA: --if you
haven't already been already.
No, if you could use
technology and content
to change one thing about the
world, what would that be--
sit on it.
NIKKI REED: Can we
ask the audience?
You guys can chime in.
It's not just for us.
JENNA ORTEGA: If anybody
has any ideas, feel free.
LISA EDELSTEIN: Yes, energy.
I feel like--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LISA EDELSTEIN: --has
a future without that,
all these young people.
The most important thing in
the world is our environment,
and fixing that.
All the problems we have
to do with our environment.
ROSARIO DAWSON:
Internally and externally.
LISA EDELSTEIN: Yeah,
so here's to you guys.
Come up with a solution.
JULIE BOWEN: We
left you a big one.
LISA EDELSTEIN: We're
counting on you.
ROSARIO DAWSON: Well, that's
the thing, though, right?
Because we're still here.
And we're a part of it, so we're
counting on you, not like, OK,
the buck's passed on to you.
We're counting on you to
join us and work with us.
LISA EDELSTEIN: Yes, ma'am.
ROSARIO DAWSON: Like
this amazing young lady
who's 15 years old who wants
to be a pediatric oncologist.
JENNA ORTEGA: Incredible.
[APPLAUSE]
Heck yeah, round of applause.
All right, I think I'm
going to jump off--
MARISA POLVINO: Should
we open this up to Q&A?
JENNA ORTEGA: Yeah, do
you guys have questions-
want to chime in?
MARISA POLVINO: Who's running--
is Katie?
Katie?
Do you have a mic?
JENNA ORTEGA: Ooh.
MARISA POLVINO: All right.
LISA EDELSTEIN: So we've
got some questions.
JENNA ORTEGA: Do
you have a question?
Raise your hand.
We have Kate over
here-- oh, here we go.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for having us here.
I know it means a lot
to all of our girls,
and we really appreciate it.
I wanted to ask, how did you
come about getting the scripts
that you used for your shorts?
Were there a few in the
running that you looked at,
did you help build
them yourself?
What was that process like?
NIKKI REED: We were all
paired with a young writer who
had never written a
screenplay before.
And the process was a
really wonderful one
because we kind of nurtured
the development of the project,
and had the opportunity
to kind of be
a part of that first
experience for that writer.
But it was an
interesting experience.
JULIE BOWEN: It was
interesting for the writers,
because I immediately--
we discussed the whole project
with Marisa, and my friend Rob,
and Jonas, who's
another producer.
And I thought, OK, got
it, got it, got it,
and I know exactly
the female writer.
And they said, the
one thing is, we
would like you to collaborate
with a male writer.
And I was like, why?
I thought this is
about the ladies.
They're like, no, it's
about working together.
And I was like
(DEJECTED TONE) oh.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
I missed that.
Like [WHOOSH] I was really ready
to just be a castrating lady--
person.
But I did know some--
I knew I wanted to
do something light.
And I approached
some friends who
had written on "Modern Family,"
and some comedy friends.
And one of them took the
bait, and I worked with him.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNA ORTEGA: This
is a question I have.
Did any of you guys like--
so going back to the different
technologies that were used,
did you know those
were real things?
Like I know, for me,
when I read the script,
I was like, there's
self-driving cars?
That's a real thing in,
like, Arizona or something.
They started Waymo.
Shout out to Waymo.
Yeah, that's a real
thing, and that really
caught me off my feet.
So did any of you guys have
any idea that was happening?
ANA BRENDA CONTRERAS: I
was Googling and YouTubing
everything all the time,
like, oh my god, this is real,
I have to learn more about this.
So, yeah.
LISA EDELSTEIN: I had
a meeting with Jacquard
to try to figure out how to
create future technology that
felt reasonable, that felt
like we could get there.
So I was inspired by a thing
that they do right now, which
is with holograms.
Which, mine's not
holograms, it's 3D printing.
But you can do this thing with
holograms where you take, like,
your 2 year old to
this hologram place,
and they do a hologram
of them having breakfast.
And then when your
kid's 13, they
can have breakfast
with themselves
by putting on those
glasses and just kind of
sit with themselves.
And so I thought that
was really a cool concept
of storing memory digitally.
So with mine, I
made it a 3D print,
as an idea of 30 years in
the future or whatever.
JENNA ORTEGA: That's
amazing that you just
grew from that idea.
There's so much--
LISA EDELSTEIN: They're like,
no, you can't do a hologram,
we already have a hologram.
Damn it.
[CHUCKLING]
JENNA ORTEGA: It worked.
It worked, and it
definitely inspired.
Anybody else?
NIKKI REED: I read an
article about a woman
who had been in a really
terrible car accident.
And they were working on moving
in this direction for her,
and I felt really
inspired by it.
And the technology,
unless something
has changed in the last year
and a half, wasn't developed,
but it made me want
to tell that story.
It was a very emotional
piece to read,
and that was two-dimensional.
So I thought seeing this
come to life would be--
anyway.
JENNA ORTEGA: Absolutely.
It was like a beautiful
hybrid of technology and art.
It was really beautiful.
NIKKI REED: Thanks.
JENNA ORTEGA: Yeah.
Cool, any more questions?
Oh, we have a
question right here.
Nice hair, by the way.
I like it.
It's cool.
SPEAKER 1: Got a Google
microphone for you.
JENNA ORTEGA: Oh, wow.
AUDIENCE: I'm fancy now.
How is all of this
going to be shown
to the rest of the world who
couldn't come here today?
Because obviously you can't fit
an entire world in this room.
JENNA ORTEGA: So this Friday,
it's going to be on YouTube.
It's going to be on YouTube.
MARISA POLVINO: On
the Power On channel.
JENNA ORTEGA: Yeah.
So go tell your
friends, check it out.
MARISA POLVINO: Subscribe.
JENNA ORTEGA: Subscribe, yes.
Share, repost, do all that.
Any more questions?
JULIE BOWEN: Did you
plant her in the audience?
That was an excellent question.
MARISA POLVINO: We planted
a few people around.
Oh, there's a--
LISA EDELSTEIN: I think
there's a question there.
MARISA POLVINO: Caroline,
there's a girl in the back.
AUDIENCE: I'm allowed
to throw it to you,
but I feel like it would--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
These stories are
fiercely important,
and I really appreciated the
spectrum of representation.
One thing that was really
central that I appreciated
was the importance on
women and relationships
that girls have with one
another and with other people.
I'd love to hear a little
bit about how you maintain
the authenticity of
those relationships,
and I'd love to hear
how you maintain
the authenticity of the
representation spectrum
that you've showcased
in these stories today.
JULIE BOWEN: Well,
I had sisters,
and I know that you
can love them and fight
with them all day long.
So that felt authentic to me.
As far as being representational
in the microcosm,
I thought that girls
fight and girls love,
and they don't have to
be mutually exclusive.
ANA BRENDA CONTRERAS:
Well, I'm so happy that you
made that question.
Because for me, it was really
important to find a story with
a Mexican-American family--
[APPLAUSE]
--and to do a film
where you can actually
speak in English and Spanish.
Because there's this
stereotype and cliche
that Mexicans-- or
Latinos, for that matter--
can only do certain jobs.
And I really wanted
to raise the awareness
and to tell young
girls and young boys
out there that maybe the next
Steve Jobs can have a Latino
last name, you know?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
So I know the struggle,
I know that it's
changing, little by little.
It takes a lot of work, but
I wanted to do a little bit,
and try to like just put
[INAUDIBLE] "mi granito"
that in.
[APPLAUSE]
ROSARIO DAWSON: I
have some of my cast
here if they want to stand up.
What's up?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
You, too, Zoe.
MARISA POLVINO: Zoe, you too.
ROSARIO DAWSON: Zoe.
Zoe, that's you, too.
[LAUGHTER]
So, I worked with
some of my besties,
which was the best thing.
And I was just really
grateful that the girls really
got along with each other.
They're totally different
human beings, as all of us are.
But it was just really
beautiful to see.
Because they're so professional,
and they're so talented,
and they're so creative,
they were just really
able to make characters and
personalities shine through,
even though we didn't
create these really
specific certain dynamics
to kind of really
go, well, what kind of music do
you think that girl listens to,
or whatever.
It kind of came out
through their fashion,
and their behavior,
and just these moments
that they created that just
really individualized them.
And it just was really
beautiful to see everything
that they brought.
Because we didn't-- as we
don't-- have that much time.
So much had to be in
between the lines.
And it just really
resonates and, it just
feels really authentic.
I felt like I know these girls.
I believe these girls.
I could see them at school,
going in completely different
directions.
But I could also see them
showing up at the treehouse
later and going, well, this
is what I figured out today,
and let's pool it and make
something really special.
And it didn't have to be that
they were exactly the same
and loved all the same things.
Actually, what was best was
that they had their differences.
And those differences
gave them strength
because it allowed them,
when they collaborated,
to make something
that each of them
individually couldn't
do on their own.
And I just think that's
a really critical thing,
is to recognize, when you see
so many leaders and people
in spaces, they've
got assistants,
and all these different people
who are working with them.
It's like an
extension of a brain.
No one person has
all that information.
They go, and you're
either Googling it,
or you're going out to your
community and kind of going,
OK, cool, I need to get
this done by this time;
who's got this, and who's got
that, and how can we do this?
And it's like an
expansion of your brains.
If you have that
community of people
you can rely on that are
really going to show up,
suddenly it doesn't matter
that you don't know it,
because you all know it.
And now it's known, and now
it can be that much better.
I just think that
really resonated.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
LISA EDELSTEIN: I've got my
sisters over here, McKayla
and Princess.
Please stand up.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
So beautiful.
[CHUCKLING]
They're so beautiful.
And I really wanted
to try to touch
on how Lulu,
Princess's character,
couldn't cure
cancer, but she could
use the power of her
imagination to take
her sister on these journeys
that she so desperately needed.
And it was the idea that
it's your imagination,
as young people,
that give us promise,
and that can change
anything and everything.
Even though she couldn't
save her sister,
she changed the quality
of her life completely.
And I just love
their connection--
so sweet.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
ROSARIO DAWSON: Amazing.
JENNA ORTEGA: So talented.
NIKKI REED: I think I
wanted to tell a story
that spoke about the--
you know, there's a real lack
of gender diversity in STEM
fields, but there's also a real
lack of cultural diversity,
and I think that's what we're
all up here trying to say.
And I don't know what
the up-to-date stats are,
but I think it's something like
14% or 20% of STEM fields--
it's an appallingly low number--
are women.
And I also loved the idea of
flipping a story on its head
and letting the
girl save the boy.
I remember, when
we started writing,
I think the first draft--
and Adam, if you're here,
please don't kill me because
I could be making this up--
but I feel like there
was a conversation of,
should Andy be the
girl, and the boy
comes in and saves the girl?
And I immediately said, no, it's
got to be the other way around.
And not only that, I
don't feel like you
see in film very often platonic
relationships between girls
and boys.
It's always a love story.
But those exist in real life.
And some of the most important
relationships I have in my life
are platonic relationships
with the opposite sex.
And I feel like as much
as we're in a movement--
[APPLAUSE]
--as much as we're
in a movement that
is all about women
and supporting women,
and I love that, I
also think we need
to remember to be inclusive of
these wonderful men that are
a part of all of our stories.
And it's not about exclusivity,
it's about inclusivity.
[APPLAUSE]
MARISA POLVINO:
Any more questions?
LISA EDELSTEIN: Yes.
MARISA POLVINO: Oh, over there?
JENNA ORTEGA:
Question over here.
MARISA POLVINO:
Dunebug, I see you.
AUDIENCE: What was the story
behind you guys casting
the people?
How did you cast them?
LISA EDELSTEIN: We
had casting sessions.
MARISA POLVINO: Yeah,
we had casting sessions.
LISA EDELSTEIN: People come in,
and they read from the script,
they play the
character in the room.
And we have all
different girls come in.
Some of them don't get the job.
But it's so beautiful to
see people come and try
and take on these roles.
And I think all of
us, as actors, it's
really important
to us that we make
it a safe space for
people to get the job
or even not get the job.
Princess actually-- she came in,
she read it, and it was fine.
And then I sort of re-explained
the whole meditation
about infinity, and she
just burst into tears.
[CHUCKLING]
It was such a beautiful moment.
To have a real moment
in an environment that
can be so stressful is a
really magical experience.
And so sometimes
it can be great,
and sometimes it
can be terrible.
But that was the process.
JULIE BOWEN: I have to agree.
That was the best--
that was the highest and the
lowest part of the process,
because all of us have
been in that room, over,
and over, and over.
And sometimes it feels
so deeply personal,
and it's not, when
you're the person.
And so I really felt
a responsibility--
and I'm sure the
other women did, too--
to make the people that
were coming in to read
feel like their work and
their time was valued.
So often you're left
just sitting in a room
somewhere, for hours.
You don't know what's
going on and why.
We saw so many wonderful
actresses for my short.
And I was heartbroken that
I couldn't cast them all.
And I wish that I
could call younger me
and be like, it's not about you.
Sometimes, it's just
about somebody else.
[AUDIENCE CHUCKLING]
ANA BRENDA CONTRERAS: It
was so hard for me as well.
Because all these pretty,
amazing little girls
were in there.
And I was like, can I just
cast them all, please?
And I remember when Ariana came
in-- she's somewhere here--
I started crying.
Because I was like, I can't
believe she's so beautiful.
And in a way, I understood
that that's a really hard job.
And now I totally look
at it so different.
Whenever I go in and cast,
it's like, OK, I get it,
it's hard for you as
well, so it's all right.
So also, in a way,
Power On changed me,
because now I don't
suffer anymore
whenever I go into casting.
[APPLAUSE]
MARISA POLVINO: We
have one more question.
NIKKI REED: Wait, on that note,
really quickly, can I just--
Bella and Derek, and
Thomas Dekker are here,
and Rosario is here,
of course, as well.
Gina couldn't make it
tonight, but can I just
say thank you, guys,
wherever you are.
Are you here.
I see Bella.
MARISA POLVINO: Yay, Bella.
[APPLAUSE]
NIKKI REED: There you are.
Hi, sweetie.
You guys have all
grown up so much.
It's hard-- I don't
recognize anyone.
And Thomas Dekker is somewhere.
Maybe he's being shy,
which is not like Thomas,
but he might be.
Anyway, thank you guys so much.
You're so wonderful
in this film.
And thank you for being
a part of this with me.
[APPLAUSE]
MARISA POLVINO: Do we
have time for one more?
AUDIENCE: I got the mic,
but it's [INAUDIBLE]
MARISA POLVINO:
Anyone out there?
AUDIENCE: Well, my question,
I guess, is kind of quick.
I just feel like
the doors for women
are opening in a lot of areas,
which is wonderful, tons
of room to grow, obviously.
But there's so many
young people here.
And I think it would be
really awesome to hear
a story that you had
in your younger years,
that you felt that door
closing in your face
because you're female, and how
you got past it, to inspire
these young ladies so
they can recognize when
a situation like that happens.
JULIE BOWEN: There's almost
a hesitation I have--
I was talking to some
press people earlier--
I went to all-girls
schools until I was 14.
And the messaging that I was
getting at those schools--
they were excellent schools, and
at the time this was the best
messaging--
was all-women's education
is best for you,
because when you are in
a classroom with boys,
when it comes to
science and math,
the boys are going
to put their hands up
and the teacher's
going to call on them.
In a way, they were
reinforcing the stereotype.
And they did not realize the
damage that that was doing.
So I'm almost hesitant to
say, look out for this.
Because what I love is
how your experiences--
I'm looking at all
these purple ties--
these young women are probably
having a completely different
experience.
And I don't want to color it in
any way by old-school thinking.
It's just, if it excites
you, if it turns you on,
if you can't stop thinking
about it when you go to school,
and you can't wait
to compete in it,
or write it, or sing
it, or make it, do it.
LISA EDELSTEIN: That's right.
JULIE BOWEN: And that's it.
LISA EDELSTEIN: Yeah, when I was
11, when I was in sixth grade,
we had to write
essays on what we
wanted to be when we grew up.
And I wrote an essay that
I wanted to be an actress.
And everyone laughed at me.
Because by sixth grade,
boys and girls already
believed that none
of those things
were things they had access to.
They already were sitting on
top of their dreams and saying,
this won't happen--
at 11.
And so I say to you guys,
everything is possible.
Yes, if you've got
a passion, if you've
got something you're
excited about,
you go and you make that happen.
The world is yours, take it.
[APPLAUSE]
ANA BRENDA CONTRERAS:
I also think
it's very important to end
the whole "mean girl" culture.
It's like, girls, just
support your girls.
Talk to each other.
And believe me, there's going to
be a lot of blessings for you.
It's going to be all
better if you team up.
[APPLAUSE]
MARISA POLVINO:
I think we have--
anybody else?
I'm getting the
wrap-it-up comment.
Oh, my daughter wants
to ask a question,
so I have to have that happen.
JULIE BOWEN: Well,
we have to let her.
MARISA POLVINO: Dune?
Where is she?
ROSARIO DAWSON: She
also gave great feedback
when we were editing.
MARISA POLVINO:
Yep, she and Gigi.
ROSARIO DAWSON: And her friends
came through, and was like,
OK, I understand this,
what's this about?
It was great.
[ROSARIO CHUCKLING]
MARISA POLVINO: Is
she asking a question.
JULIE BOWEN: June,
talk into the box.
DUNE: OK.
MARISA POLVINO: Want to
stand up so we can see you?
DUNE: Oh my god.
MARISA POLVINO: We can
only see your head.
[JULIE GROANING, IMITATING
DUNE'S RELUCTANCE]
JULIE BOWEN: This is why she
wants a driverless car, to take
her away from her mother.
MARISA POLVINO: That's true.
DUNE: What did you feel like
after all the movies were
done--
or little show thingy?
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIE BOWEN: You mean tonight?
DUNE: Yeah, like after
you built all of them,
with all the actors, and like--
LISA EDELSTEIN: We felt
like [MUMBLING INCOHERENTLY
IN EXHAUSTED TONE]
[LAUGHTER]
JULIE BOWEN: Like,
how can five minutes
take so much out of your life?
[LAUGHTER]
And let me do some more.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: OK, So
before we wrap up,
let's think our
talented filmmakers.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]